in your books people there are a lot of
tragedies in a setback say they lose
dragons they lose their lives in the new
book leaving one guy who loses the
battle and they and they dip his skull
and gold and uses a drinking cup so
people people go through a lot and I'm
wondering what's the greatest setback
you have faced in your career I'm sure
nothing as bad as that as a big guy
but I'm just wondering what's the
greatest setback you have faced in your
professional or personal career yes they
they you know I've never been murdered
or killed or tortured or you know locked
away for 50 years so I'm much better
than a that a you know medieval trader
you know for a writer in the 20th
century two worlds of science fiction
fantasy I suppose the greatest setback I
ever faced was the failure of my fourth
novel the Armageddon rag I mean I
started publishing in 1971 my first
novel came out in 1977 I was a hot young
writer for quite a long time being
nominated for us and nebulas each novel
that I wrote got a bigger advance and
more publicity and more Awards
nominations than the one before and
until I wrote the Armageddon rag and
that seemed perfect of course it got me
the biggest advance I've gotten to date
it got great reviews it was not only a
World Fantasy Award my publishers were
certain it would be my first bestseller
and nobody bought it and I discovered
that you know if you keep rolling the
dice sooner or later they come up
boxcars I still love the Armageddon rag
I'm proud of it it's I think it's a good
novel it certainly was well reviewed and
well respected in its time but for
whatever reason it was a commercial
failure and suddenly I found I could not
sell my fifth novel suddenly I found no
one wanted my books anymore because
you're only as hot as your last success
you have a few flops in either books or
or television and and you can find
yourself your career is over so I add
Lea enough the very book that ended my
career is a novel
opened my career in Hollywood because
who is option for a film and the guy
option it for film he never got it made
as a film but he was the same guy who
CBS picked to revive to Twilight Zone
and when he did that he called me up and
say hey you want to write as Twilight
Zone script for us so suddenly I found
my zombie a television writer and that
basically saved me because you know
there was a period there when I was
unable to sell that fifth novel where I
was looking at having to sell my house
and I was I took one of those courses in
in you know buying real estate for no
money down you know in my desperation of
oh my god how am I gonna make any any
money here you know fed there may be
some aspiring writers in the audience
here some people who dreamed of writing
let me tell you it's not a job for
anyone who wants security if you want
security there's lots of nice careers
that one could have where one starts at
the bottom and climbs the rung and
ultimately there's a pension and a gold
watch at the end of it writer is not one
of those jobs it's a constant rolling of
the dice and you're gonna have great
success and suddenly it can all blow
away and that's what happened to me with
a day Armageddon ring now I was at a
book festival recently and the author of
the remains the day made the point that
he thought that writers do their best
work and they peak in their 30s and 40s
he's close to 60 years old down I'm
wondering what do you think of that
theory and how do you think aging
affects novels does it improve their
crap because they know more about the
world and do they are the people really
better when they're younger what do you
think I think it's really an individual
thing you know there is something to
what he says you you know I know the
fields of science fiction and fantasy
best and you can look at some writers in
that field and and see that yes indeed
they did do their their best work when
they were in
30s and 40s or sometimes even their 20s
some of them then at a certain point get
writer's block for something where they
suddenly seized up you mean you have a
writer i Theodore sturgeon immensely
prolific for the early part of his
career
he hits like the 60s and he spends the
last 20 years of his life working on
allegedly one novel and then he dies and
the novel finally comes out say this he
took 20 years with this it's like and
then you see other writers who continue
to be prolific but it's like you're
rewriting the same novel over again you
know this one is just like the last one
which was just like the one before that
which was just like the one before that
so it's like they're the old dog but
they don't know any new tricks however
there are also some amazing exceptions
Jack Vance one of my favorite writers
continue to write terrific books well
into his 90s Nigel Tranter the Scottish
historical novelist again continued to
work right up until his mid-90s writing
the same kind of books he'd written when
he was in his 20s so it all really
depends on on the writer and there are
writers who don't even start - they're
late I mean are a lafferty a wonderful
writer of science fiction short stories
spent his entire life as an electrician
and it's only when he retired at the age
of 65 and started collecting Social
Security that he started to write and he
had a whole second career as a as a very
weird unique but fascinating science
fiction writer you know from the ages
about 65 to 80 so it all depends on the
rail now we want to ask one or two
questions from our Twitter followers
from NWSA plus if people sent in their
questions and one question someone had
is where do you first come up with the
ideas for these books this Shane at what
the heck man
so so he asked what I loved one had to
read the actual Twitter handles now what
did it first come up with the idea for
the books does he keep tweaking as it
goes on or is every characters fate
already
the the main characters I know where I'm
going with them
but there are there are a million
secondary characters and and for those
you know I do have different ideas at
different points that's an impossible
question is read the question of where
do you get your ideas ideas like I Sarah
all around you know you just have an
idea you don't know where it comes from
there are a few cases where I
specifically know where an idea came
from I read something where I saw
something or I had an experience that
triggered an idea but those are very few
it said mostly it's just oh that would
be interesting well where did they come
from I didn't have any moment ago well
now I had it it popped up in my brain
folks see his Louis wrote that when he
came up with a chronicle of Narnia he
came up with images first the image of a
faun holding an umbrella an image of a
queen on a sledge and I'm wondering I
know you came up with the first chapter
of the book first of a boy heading for a
beheading right it was an image or event
or something that sparked that first
chapter they set you on the path to
trade in his old world not that I know
of but certainly came from somewhere but
it just came vividly and and there it
was and I had the whole chapter in my
head not just you know bran and the
beheading but also the finding and the
dire wolf pups in the summer snows I
knew that I knew it had to be the summer
snows that phrase in the summer snows
with the contradiction that it implies
tells you so much about the world was
just there and I sat down and wrote it
put aside the other book I was doing and
did that